take this meal [ __ ]
yeah
the church of what's happening now is
presented by onit
the show is brought to you by texture
the texture app lets you tap into the
world's most popular magazines anytime
anywhere using your smartphone or tablet
and get a free trial when you go to
texture.com joey that's right our
listeners get a free trial at
texture.com joey
shows also brought to you by meundies
go to meundies.com
joey right now to get 20 off of your
first order of all their men's and
women's underwear t-shirts socks and
much much more i love their sweatpants
and their shorts go to meundies.com joey
to get 20 off
of your first order
you're sitting there
thinking about who won who's the
president what am i gonna do
don't do dick all right
uncle joey's here never fear
church of what's happening now
my little goomba lisa
my main man nick detour
right
good to be here
wednesday
november 10th november 9th
get it kick it at me league kick it kick
it kick it i want the speakers blown out
lee
i'm taking you back [ __ ] to the
jersey shore
summer of 80 [ __ ] four people sucking
dick condoms blowing up
are you kidding me or what oh yeah
long island
uncle sam's
feathers eight dollars tuesday night
montego bay the [ __ ] red devils an
alabama slammer and a kamikaze put
together two quaaludes and two of those
it's over yeah you wake up in the
morning with a missing shoe you know
what i'm saying
it was a good time take that
[ __ ] mule
all night
all night [ __ ] what yeah
fighting a [ __ ] car
take it you filthy animal there you go
take it like a man go deep
deep
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
you landed on the right [ __ ]
podcast you know what i'm saying
the church of what's happening now
whatever the [ __ ] happens tonight listen
we're doing a podcast tuesday night but
obviously you're you went to bed early
you're a normal human or you're sitting
there crying and you're vodka tonic
doing coke what am i gonna do
uh president trump listen
i tell you once i tell you a thousand
times you gotta keep doing what you've
been doing you think when [ __ ] fidel
took over castro these people there was
no more there's no thought you had one
[ __ ] option so
for you people who are looking to split
i got travel agents and contacts all
over the world remember
i was always looking to split too but
where the [ __ ] are you gonna go you know
what i'm saying they say every election
no one's going to do it
and like i said before you know
we sit here in california and even
california come on you even get stuck on
burbank boulevard you're thinking you're
in [ __ ] hell yeah you know where you
go get the chicken teriyaki you would
park there and just look around you're
like this is california isn't california
this could be bayonne new jersey it's
true there's parts here look like
[ __ ] hell hit it but the people who
are in the nicer parts you know
they just see their neighborhood and
they see their nice little grandma
schools and their nice little uh
white peaches and stuff right you know
when i travel i go to places like
pittsburgh where i went as a kid when i
was a kid
i went to
the fourth grade with jackie hernandez
his
nephew octavio fernandez and he used to
get tickets and we'd go up to the
pittsburgh games whenever we wanted and
whenever the pittsburgh pirates came to
shea we were front and center [ __ ] we
knew [ __ ] jackie land there's a
shortstop with the [ __ ] afro under
the hat
and i remember going up there and
looking at those bars and going sunday
i'm gonna be able to come up here
look at the city it's alive
people talk about new york city buffalo
new york
they were syracuse rochester these are
wall cities guys that had
tons of of from fisher price to to this
to nabisco to this i don't even know
i don't even know and all of a sudden
one day they all shut down those jobs
went to somebody else yeah and like we
discussed before the show these were
people that you know
uh han soul of america yeah
your son's no [ __ ] genius you know
he's too stupid to be a marine and he's
too stupid to go to college he's either
gonna [ __ ] weld [ __ ] doors
or he's gonna go work with his dad you
know right these are people these are
[ __ ] generations of people
that have these jobs and they took them
away you know i heard buffalo you know
buffalo baseball for example the buffalo
bites license the number one attendant
since [ __ ] jesus
worked [ __ ] short skirts they got
nothing else there right you know but
still you got canada you got the
waterfall buffalo's a beautiful city
that's yeah it's made a little bit of a
comeback
but not
the heyday where they were and this is
why
it doesn't surprise me no michigan go to
michigan grand rapids
they're losing their [ __ ] jobs making
cars right they don't make no [ __ ]
cars no more
yeah but do you ever think this country
will you know be what it once was that
those places will come back and thrive
again
and then america will be like i don't
think so well i mean enemy says yes
not because of a president okay right
not because of a president but because
of commerce hopefully more businesses
open up back up in
those areas it's very tough
to open up a business right now oh yeah
it's very come on do you walk on uh
ventura boulevard everything is fleece
everything is for rent
people can't make it they can't make it
out here
people are struggling everywhere you
know it ain't no joke it's not that you
know
we're uh
it's it's gotta be better it's got the
people where we live they're all like in
shock of what's going on at this point
at this point we we have no president
yet you know we're still in limbo
trump's winning trump's losing
you know who the [ __ ] knows like i said
i'm not here to upset nobody or nothing
like this i just you have to say this
for what it is yeah
i uh
michael moore isn't someone who i am a
huge fan of i
i liked him at the beginning but then i
found out some stuff about him that made
me not like him but he said this thing
that was really uh
it really made me understand trump
because i come from a very democratic
place and he said it's just it's people
who feel
like they have nothing left
and they're angry and he's saying [ __ ]
you to them and i understand that like
but luckily i'm not in a terrible
position so i don't i don't feel that
hopeless so i don't feel hopeless or
or scared like he's saying those people
feel
but i can understand why that would make
like they're saying record people came
out to vote so they can't say that no
one came out to vote there's millions of
people waiting in line for hours so
they're just not voting for who people
wanted them to vote for
i mean this morning i woke up and
listen i'm just lazy i can go down there
and register and do the whole thing it's
been over [ __ ] 20 years since i had a
felony but
um
i don't know
i was raised in knudsen county and i saw
dirty politics as a young man it always
broke me
that was one of the things that really
broke me that was one of the things when
you come from another country
and you read about in grammar school
that you're like wow
this really exists and all of a sudden
i'd see cops coming to my mom's bar and
getting envelopes
whenever there's a mayor's ball
you had to pay for these overpriced
tickets even if you didn't show up but
if you wanted something for your bar or
something you had to show up
you know i saw um
as i got older and i moved to north
bergen i i can't tell you what i saw
it's it's it's
overwhelming and with the things i heard
and
the who i was at the time
you know i was trying to at that age i
was just trying to get accepted you know
i was a cuban kid in an all italian
irish neighborhood
and they were all into politics and i
couldn't believe it like nick i couldn't
[ __ ] believe it you know i really had
broke my spirit as uh that's why i'm not
into politics i don't believe
a word of it a word of it because i grew
up
in an environment where
that's all they talked about that's all
they did you know if you want to get
anything done you had to go to your
local guy and then he went to a guy but
at election time you had to hang your
sign under your window
and you had to knock on you speak
spanish right yeah okay you got to knock
on doors for us to re-election done and
let people know they gotta vote
and i saw how they corrupted my town
with that i saw a little small town a
thriving italian irish couple jews
couple germans
and they if you didn't vote and stuff
they wouldn't take care of your driveway
when it was supposed to shovel they
wouldn't shovel your driveway
i mean they would do the little minute
things just to let you know that they
know you didn't vote that way you know
but
you want
nick jr
to play in the in the county league you
got to vote right you know it was some
of that [ __ ] so
i saw it in the microwave and then
when as i got old i read about the
kennedys and you read about
you know this guy and that guy and you
go it's the same [ __ ] only in a bigger
picture right you know where i came from
it's a hundred dollar day movie this is
scale
you know this is [ __ ] scary right
let's say you start so
and you want to assume otherwise so it
broke me it broke my uh
my spirit you know i i look at the
elections
this one more than the last whatever how
old i am is a [ __ ] joke
this one was a real
it's not as much of a joke as an eye
opener
absolutely yeah i agree yeah that's true
but you know it was bound to happen
something like this was
it wasn't trump maybe it was somebody
like trump you know
um
he just started to explain that you know
someone could get that far
and now maybe pull off the impossible
dream but it is a weird night i know
it's just weird i come over here and i'm
like
there's something weird in the air i
don't know what's gonna happen but
you know
you feel like oh if that happens what's
next you know but really like you said
tomorrow's another day you gotta get up
you gotta go out you gotta get a job you
know you gotta you gotta continue to
live right
so hopefully we'll survive no matter
what happens but it's just hope for the
best and pray
i mean i i've seen things nick
you know i mean after 9 11 how could you
ever be the same i don't know i was in
the jersey shore when that happened then
i was blown away i almost traveled that
week and
you know it's just like after 9 11 it's
like you know i've just seen the
differences in quality of life
i just see the differences in quality of
life
and a person like me in my core bothers
me because
i was raised to believe that you got
your money's worth you know
you go get a plane ticket in this
country today
it's a rape right off the bat god forbid
nick gave you the wrong date and you got
to switch that they want to charge you
200 for a [ __ ] change fee
you know we're getting charged for
luggage ladies and gentlemen yeah you
know when i was a kid and i say this i
stress this because i you know when i
was a kid i was hearing how bad the
country was
and what one day you went to grammar
school and on the billboard at grammar
school it said tonight
uh
city tryouts
come on down everybody gets put on the
team whether you were stupid they had
glasses they put you on the team you got
a t-shirt right it cost you who gots
yeah it didn't cost you a dollar to play
pay for this and your kids came for 10
weeks and that you knew where they were
on friday nights and at the end of the
season they give out trophies and
there's a pizza party and you pay you
don't go for nothing i see parents now
that they sign their kids up they got to
pay 35 for the t-shirt they ra my wife
came to me today she goes do you want to
sign up mercy for the next two quarters
in soccer
i go can't we sign her up for one and
see when she's at at that point
and he goes now you got to sign her for
two i know how much is two she goes 400
and 26 dollars for two whatever for
[ __ ] uh
you know yeah there's two coaches the
one coach coaches the men's the other
guy uh
habib whatever [ __ ] great kid irene
coach whatever loves my daughter i love
him
gives my daughter the respect and the
other girls and the kids you know uh for
426 [ __ ] dollars yeah this is a city
league league for taunt for the kids
soccer she's [ __ ] full what is she
paylay what is this
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] you gotta go
home and scratch your [ __ ] that is an
american and go what the [ __ ] has
happened what the [ __ ] has happened come
on i mean yeah i'm 50 [ __ ] three
years old and what i see is a [ __ ]
disgrace i go to the pump it's three
dollars remember [ __ ] i travel
you can't come to make a nocino going to
cuento
i travel i go to places 1.78 and i'm
like where the [ __ ] am i that dollar's
two dollars a [ __ ] gallon i just paid
three [ __ ] dollars two nights ago
when i left here you know we get re you
know what that is that as an american i
pay 25 for suitcase
that's ridiculous unless you're a gold
class and yes i travel but you know what
man let me tell you something every no
matter what the [ __ ] i do no matter what
the [ __ ] i do and you can ask lisa you
have this i always say to myself
how can an american family afford this
anymore
how does an american family tell your to
your daughter and your son we're going
to brooklyn to see my grandmother's
grave and my brother for the christmas
four four four four that's 1600 200 in
suitcases how much for a hotel in queens
in the [ __ ] end for a shopping lift
you might even get robbed you got to put
your [ __ ] in a safe in the safe with a
gun 2 34 or one night you're trying to
stay a week
unless [ __ ] breakfast is included
you'll die i know your family dies it's
like you can't go to a baseball game
and i love baseball you know i love it
but i mean i gotta pay to watch it on tv
when i was a kid you know maybe we got
40 games a year and wpix 11 listened on
the radio and if we went to a game i had
10 bucks for the day and a dollar fifty
for the grandstand would sneak around we
could buy a helmet a buck 50 my mother
would pack a lunch and uh you know 10 12
bucks 15 bucks i got a ticket from 1976
to chris chandler's game eight bucks for
a box seat in a game five deciding alcs
game i mean that's unbelievable but you
know the money meant something you
didn't have a lot but you could get away
with it and today you're gonna what are
you gonna go for 500 for a baseball game
and get a family of four
who can afford that i could afford it
like a game you know any basketball
games i went to i tagged down with like
lee's family lee would say man my father
wants to know
if you want to come to the game with us
this is an extra ticket
and you tagged on and i bought my own
popcorn
i said thank you to your mom
you can't do that no more no how much is
a laker game now that you've either take
your family i know you make a trek down
there once a year you try i like a game
it's 200 a seat 140 yeah 140 probably
about 140 or something for a decent for
a decent season so fortunately it's with
a family i had a ticket for the ram game
today 140 dollars it was a decent seat i
ran game and then enough 80 bucks to
park or 50 bucks
50 dollars is cheap most places are
charging 80 to 100 to park the car
that's what i'm saying i'm going to go
down
see this is this is what i'm saying i'm
saying this is why i don't get involved
that's why i don't go unless someone's
giving it people joey you don't go to
enough concerts you know why guys
because when i see
i went uh two years ago i went to the
meadowlands not the meadowlands the one
in newark
my brother drove me he ate a [ __ ]
piece of banana bread he [ __ ] freaked
out i would have freaked out too parking
was fifty dollars yeah how can a family
afford that so
listen i don't know all the [ __ ]
bylaws and laws i don't have the time
i know you guys as decent americans the
people who listen to the podcast you
know more you're in tune more with laws
and taxes and
i'm to the point in my life when i go to
the airport i'm to the point in my life
when i go to get a plane ticket now
and i look at the price
i check what am i gonna do i got a gun
to my head i know there's two ways to
fly you could fly like a [ __ ] animal
okay there's three ways to fly you could
fly like an animal you could fly like a
[ __ ] mid-level
animal or you could fly like a human
being i tell you what i mugged a few
type of people in my life i snorted coke
i did a few bad things i'll sit in the
second section
it costs you money
to sit in that second section now
they will put you in a dungeon which
they'll put you in the back with rapists
and people that are transferring from a
facility to the facilities
it's [ __ ] bad on those flights and
they treat you like [ __ ] by the time
you're on the plane there's nowhere to
put your luggage that's horrible it's
horrible it's [ __ ] a horrible way and
i'm telling you i fly twice a month
and i do it as easy as possible because
in my mind i've already accepted it as
something i have to do right but
sometimes and these comedy clubs give me
an allowance for flights i have to call
them back and go listen i gotta bump you
you gotta lift the rock that that that
that that nickel you're giving me that's
short
yeah that nickel short i can't fly that
by a lot probably not like 20 bucks like
by like 140 or 200 you sit there me and
my wife look at the plane tickets at the
end of the year and go
how the [ __ ] does this happen you know i
got everything
nick i got everything
i got every audition i've been on since
2001.
you do okay casting director how i did
the result i mean you write it down why
not
you write everything down and i found
them on this last move i found them
you found who
the the notebooks i found even more
notebooks like i knew i had to like two
thousand
maybe nine in my possessions right next
to me
so something should ever happen i could
go on my notebook and go no the last
time i went in for that [ __ ] was
wow and when i go in to see her i'll
tell her yeah remember the last time i
saw you it was for papa you're not gonna
believe what happened with that piece of
[ __ ] producer we all wanted you they
always tell you the same thing right we
all wanted you but the producer wanted
the chinese kid with the missing eyeball
and you're like okay already you know
i'm saying the movie was horrible so but
you want to tell them like i wanted to
see you once before you want to break
the ice you know i got all that [ __ ]
nick and i had i found
plane ticket prices
from the longest yard tour oh really
gosh you know what i was paying for
plane tickets that
uh 2005. were you flying yourself yeah
like they would call me a comedy club to
headline me i was booked by an agency
for like four weeks they found out i was
snorting blood they never called me back
and
do i end the long shot
no no when the longest shot came what i
did was when we were filming the longest
yard yeah i had those dudes blowing
smoke on my ass yeah and they told me to
get a booking agent i couldn't get a
booking agent to save my life
and one day i bumped into bill byrne i
go bill burnt this movie was gonna be
big he hooked me up and he hooked me up
with one of his guy's assistants
and the guy booked me like four weeks
and he calls me one day and goes dog i
don't know if i told you i'm going back
to my job in chicago you don't have an
agent no more over here so they sent me
a bill like years later when i sent the
collection i had to go i had the receipt
you know i saved all that [ __ ] but i
saved like the plane tickets
you know when i come back from a gig the
first thing i do is i get the two plane
tickets i get the check that they paid
me i get the amount of the room
i get the the the parking from the
airline you save all the restaurants you
save all those receipts oh you do yeah i
save all that stuff
so i could compare years later what it
cost me to fly there sometimes i use
miles lee you have to do this i'm not
laughing at you
you're you're kind of a you're a nerd
you
you like looking back and and comparing
it's just for fun for you it's very
informative
it really opens your eyes when you do it
we don't want to do it right because
your head will blow the [ __ ] up
your head will blow the [ __ ] up
it's like when you thought you were in
shape during that film i was in
tremendous shape you look at that pitch
and go oh my god i had 19 chins yeah
what the [ __ ] was i thinking
what workout did i do before that i
walked a few times to get lunch boxes
and [ __ ]
you know the same thing goes when you
look at what like i don't say receipts
from clothes nothing like that i'm not
one of those nerds but whenever i go on
the road for some reason i always say
that [ __ ] what if i got accused of
murdering somebody right and i'm gonna
use to network and i have to receive
from performing
i got everything you know i'm saying
excuse me so
i looked at like 2005 specifically
i paid
290 for a round-trip ticket to newark
from lax on
it's not united the other one
continental the one that merged yeah
that one continental no plane ticket it
wasn't a good one i sat next to some
[ __ ] that was the one that they
wanted the police greeted me
because i had the foreigners next to me
and i took my cell phone out and they
threatened me they kept telling me to
turn it off turn it off you know the
store this always says she tells you to
shut it down right after 2000 right
after 211 they were real strict about it
yeah but come on 297 to newark go look
up newark from lax now
i know they [ __ ] club at you and and
nine out of 10 of my connections that's
why you gotta keep searching search and
i tell them when they're looking for
flights what about i said just keep
looking keep looking until something
pops up cheap
but sometimes it does no because lee
informed me
that the [ __ ] they they know who you are
now oh yeah so what you have to do is
look at the plane ticket on your
computer and go to somebody else's and
buy it oh really and then do the same
and the same and because if not they
know who you are so next time you're on
youporn jerking off
you're ready to come there's a little
thing that goes
and it goes
go from lax to ohio right for 312. and
also you're gonna go wait a second
how did that [ __ ] know i need a
plane ticket who's watching me you put
your dick back in your shirts like
somebody's watching me no yeah because
now everybody knows you look for a plane
ticket there so every time you go on the
computer i don't know what it's called
please forgive me i'm not a computer
dude
but i look at all that years ago they
had the people's express and those
things i mean i i put them out of
business single-handedly with fake
credit cards oh you did oh please why go
on there with a real [ __ ] jimmy i
would go on there with somebody else's
credit card buying drinks give the girl
in row 11a a cocktail on me
i'm the captain kirk of this [ __ ]
flight
oh that's nice man when do you like when
you should i look up for tickets now huh
like what what like what dates like when
should i fly do you think cause should i
fly during the holidays
excuse me like when should i look for
tickets when you where are you going to
new york
oh i'm just teasing i'm just talking
listen there used to be a thing when i
first moved here in 1997 okay i know for
a [ __ ] fact i have that [ __ ]
calling right now
tomorrow you gotta call nick what's
tomorrow wednesday mm-hmm wednesday in
1997 i know this for a fact if you got a
call
and they said listen nick this is it
this is last shot you gotta i'm sorry we
have to call you wednesday but you have
to be in new york friday if you want
this new dinero movie it's got meryl
streep jesus is making a comeback you
know this guy this guy
you got but uh
it's christmas time i gotta fly myself
in there listen nick
get here and then we'll talk about the
specifics all right book the [ __ ] job
and then we'll give you guinness but
enough i can't go through a plane ticket
now do what you gotta do to get here and
you're sitting there going uh my kids
need this there was a service back then
that you called 1-800 and i never forget
calling them and the guy who turned me
onto him was josh wolfe
oh yeah in those days
you would call this 800 number and go i
want to go from here to here
we got a ticket it's
167 plus tax
it would be 199 201
the catch was you had to go to the
airport right before you pull into the
airport you make a right in those days
right you gotta run in there and there
was a line in there that bingo
from [ __ ] here to eternity there's a
line in there so if you had a flight at
one you had to go down there eight in
the morning right and wait online to get
the ticket for 200 hours but you would
fly
delta
you know row 11 d you sat in the inside
next to the lady with the dog yeah
eating cottage cheese and the stink of
[ __ ] her feet
hey
you know try flying uh with body passes
i did that for a couple years with blue
bloods and a friend of ours works for
the airlines and she would list me for
these flights and flights that looked
like impossible she'd be like nick
you're never gonna get on
and then i would go and she said you're
the luckiest son of a [ __ ] ev it's
unbelievable how you get on and not only
when i get on
i get on first class are you serious
yeah because she would list me
and then i would look like an airline
and then people wouldn't recognize me
and go how come you're a d3
you know do you work for the airline i
go no
you know and then and then i would
somehow someway i almost was like 95
that i never
like never got on the flight flights
that were like booked but you got to do
it by yourself if you do it with a few
people
it's hard because no no you can't lead
something for 14 people no i know that
you got to fly by yourself but i had to
get there you know there were times that
i had a i had a you know i always
remember somebody died
listen you can't get me on the next
fight i got an uncle he fell off a
building
yeah
that's a people acting oh yeah you can
do that that's when you got to go deep
into them and talk to you over here
right who's running it who's running
this place i got some of these guys that
traveled with their dogs you know they
got these letters that they said they
got a nervous condition they're walking
on there with a rottweiler and i'm like
how the hell you get how are you going
on there with a pit bull and then you
got a letter he was like yeah i got a
letter you know but it's like i felt bad
taking the door i saw a chick with
tremendous tits with a service dog i
wanted to kick her in the [ __ ] mouth
you understand me yeah she had the best
tits in the world she had all the
confidence you need and she had what a
dog would have a little bit was it a big
dog like half size whatever good looking
dog too but yeah you know meanwhile
you're going to travel with this paul
guys to put him in a little bag and has
to push his head in
to stuff his head he'd always try to pop
he was a good little dog the dog i got a
bulldog now i couldn't have traveled
a [ __ ] dog dog no i can't do it now i
can't do it i don't have the patience
i have a system to fly and i like to
stay to that [ __ ] system you know
we're in bed virgin america they're not
bad virgin america tremendous the
biggest scam of the business you're the
main cabin selector i know maine captain
celeste hours the night before one when
when placed a show main cabin select
aisle seat right you're living like a
doctor and you're getting that from
uncle joey main cabin select
and god forbid you got an extra deuce in
your pocket you wake up at three in the
morning let's say your flight's at
[ __ ] six
let's say your flight's at 705 right
you put you set the alarm for uh you go
to bed at night you eat some volumes
maybe you drink a dirty [ __ ] harry
what's that the the chocolate drink with
the white milk and the vodka and the
kalua uh oh my russian you do a white
russian one of those valiums night night
time ain't nobody waking yet you wake up
at one
six hours before the fight takes off if
you're sitting in the main cabin so like
you call virgin they bump you right up
to first class oh wow they give you a
hard time for a second who are you what
do you know yeah who sent you you know
who the [ __ ] are you hold on one second
also in some australian guy comes on and
he's like listen we got you covered this
time don't pull this [ __ ] ever again
and you get on first class with virgin
and you live like a doctor it's only
eight people right in first class you
feed her up yeah they got those disco
lights you know who i saw destroy first
class on virgin ralphie may
as soon as he calls virgin i just hang
up on him
he [ __ ] him up he [ __ ] him up what
do you do he from beginning to end he
was living like [ __ ] king for that
[ __ ] really with his feet up
getting cokes he must have drank nine
cokes on the way to new york city i was
sitting there howling
i'm sitting there ralphie may will [ __ ]
up an airline
cookies towels blankets he needs two
blankets he has the time together
it's nice to fly right bud you know when
you're flying no because you're like you
know the [ __ ] price it is to fly
right oh my god i just paid 200 bucks
four because you you're very generous
and you're paying for my flight to
boston who says who told you that i
ain't paying for the dick [ __ ] anyway
[ __ ] it i'm gonna cancel this then
anyways you know what you know i'm tight
with my wallet but i was in 22c
like i was in the i was in 22 both ways
and
like i was gonna i was hoping it was
gonna be like 20 bucks to upgrade it was
100 bucks each way but at least i get oh
my god at least i get this is what i'm
talking about so do you understand me
ladies and gentlemen i'm sorry to
interrupt you but this is my point
you're an american you're working hard
every week let's pretend let me pretend
with you you make [ __ ] uh where's my
pen here who's got the [ __ ] right here
let's pretend let's pretend as an
american you make 600 a week if you're
lucky
600 a [ __ ] week if you're lucky all
right what do you take home from that
420
420 yeah that's 16 [ __ ] 80 a month
think about it
think about it how much money could this
possible poor soul
put away after rent
car payment food insurance which is
[ __ ] astronomical in this country at
this point
you got to walk around with a rabbit's
foot a santeria chicken on your neck
yeah a yarmulker and now guess how much
my health insurance is next year 400 a
month a month 400.
four [ __ ] hundred a month so do you
understand me i mean
i don't know
who's going to change this
i don't know i don't know who discussed
this than their [ __ ]
i don't know
you know but this is what needs to be
addressed
that level of america needs to be
addressed again to live again to live
again yeah that way of america
there is no reason why
the rents
are astronomically
the rents astronomical levels
in a place where you're not going to get
stabbed
in my
tiny like maybe 600 square foot
apartment the next time it goes up in
june it's gonna be 1400 a month
1400 i was thinking about that because
for the first time in two and a half
years i just i forgot to pay rent this
month she texted me and she was like we
haven't got your checks i ran down
and when i moved there was 1200
and they keep raising 50 bucks every
year
and like
it's not that it's not
like i i kind of want to ask what that
apartment is now i'm sure it's like 15
16 1600 a month
i'm sure it is
because they just keep raising every
year listen when i bought my first house
in 96
mom was doing pretty good just got an
nypd blue the house was going for 419.
uh
south of the boulevard tarzana beautiful
spread i mean had a pool that looked
like a pond
and i'm thinking oh [ __ ] foreign i get
that i said can i afford that i never
you know i'm a kid from new york i don't
know i thought a hundred thousand twenty
dollars sounded a lot and
they said yeah yes we get the house for
380. i said wow you know my heart was
pounding i wasn't making huge money
and then you know i was like and at that
time i thought 380 400 was you know now
you know what you could get for 380.
you can't get [ __ ] you can't get
shipping you get a million dollars a
tear down you get houses now where i'm
living now it's like they're they tear
the builders coming to tear them down
how could you as a young person starting
out
you know
how do you and how do you make it i mean
how do you like unless you're like
starting with a big you know big capital
or this or that but i mean like at least
and that wasn't that long ago 96 98 and
then you know when everything went sky
high and that that when the whole
mortgage scam thing but then it came
down it shot back up now it's so high
again nobody can buy anything you know
so what's gonna you know things
things just got out of hand never got
corrected i don't know i don't know what
the answer is i don't think it's one
person i don't know either that's the
thing that i wish i was more
knowledgeable on the subject but i got
my own problems i know over the years i
just said you know what you lose sight
of that i was [ __ ] scarred
towards politics i i get it it is what
it is uh but i don't really have like a
belief in it i don't know why and
i've tried i really tried you know
the police has changed over the last 20
years the police's attitude has changed
you know i don't know if it's the
internet but every day i gotta wake up
yeah and somebody's getting hit in the
head or shot or tased or whatever
you know every [ __ ] day see i don't
know if this if i didn't see this
because i wasn't as active on the
computer right 20 years ago i don't
[ __ ] know what it is too much
everywhere you go you're recorded if you
fought they know where you fought it if
you went to if you sneezed they knew
where you sneezed
it's really like almost it's too much
now i have to talk to my brother about
that instead of years ago you go to a
pay phone make a call i gotta go to a
pay phone how you know what i mean
today everything
is documented it's too much it's too
much it's like sports i love sports but
it's so saturated it's boring it's
freaking boring you know it's like it's
not like nothing is special anymore
going to the movies was an event we went
to see the godfather when we were kids
my father said i'm going to take the
whole family way to go wait around the
block in queens at the elmwood it was an
event it meant something
you know you went to a show abroad it
meant something now these kids
everything is like give me give me give
me give me give me say hey hey hey hey i
gotta survive man you understand
i'm not that guy anymore maybe i was
that guy i'm not that guy i'd like to be
that guy but i ate that guy you know
it's crazy
we come from a different world man where
you know we went to a driving movie
theater they drew a blanket over our
head and we were in the backseat of the
uh the station wagon it was great
those were you know those were special i
feel like i lived and i still do that
you do it yeah i did like six months ago
bring that back then i didn't have the
blanket but i was in the driveway
you went through it where is that
driving ah [ __ ] it's it's down in a
weird i don't know i can look it up out
here yeah yeah it's only like an hour
away oh i love that it's a father yeah
you remember that thing the radio used
to put on put on the windows yeah radios
worked and suddenly no with the long
string yeah they're still they've
modernized a lot of driving feeders they
did it's just that
people want to go and be more
comfortable now it's a different [ __ ]
america there's no station wagons
the drive-in is way more comfortable
than the movie theater
because then no one is talking and
ruining the movie right other than maybe
tell me what that thing is i want to
watch it but every 10 minutes you got to
put the defroster on
it's a [ __ ] nightmare ladies i know
nobody's talking what movie did you go
to that people are talking about the
movies nobody says two [ __ ] words i
sit there nobody chit chat nobody does
nothing
even a movie is a lot of money you know
you go to a movie now
they rape you
that's why i don't want to go see a
piece of [ __ ] movie
it better be good because i know it's
what is it 16 bucks 14 bucks
and you buy a popcorn
you buy a soda you're going for two
people 50 60. if you got a couple of
kids it's a hundred bucks
in the same building
there used to be a podcast
and it was two girls and they discussed
movies
but in those days this had to be
i was off the blow this is probably
2008
2009. i'm still living in hollywood
and they call me up and they go we'd
like for you to be on the podcast to
discuss two movies they go what are the
two movies
and one movie was an animated movie
and the other movie was some [ __ ]
movie you know
and the movie the other one i went to
see in the daytime and it sucked yes
but the other movie only was at the arc
light
i don't know about the artwork
my wife comes home like what do you want
to do she goes oh no listen
i gotta go to this [ __ ] thing i gotta
go see it anyway so once you come with
me let's eat and then we'll make it a
night yeah we went somewhere we got some
[ __ ] snack or something and we went
down there
i went in there with a hundred dollar
bill
to the lock yeah clay
i got home with 40 70. yeah i didn't
know this until i got home
you know those things that you don't
even really notice all right
i just paid 53
yeah to see a movie to see a [ __ ]
movie was i angry
no the arc light is tremendous
they got that [ __ ] chicken hot dog
with the mustard and the onions
i haven't never had that one you eat a
chicken hot dog you didn't know that not
chicken hot dog let me excuse myself
okay because lee will take it personally
i will go home with peter check out my
dog
you you you you weigh them no no no no
no
and the one on sunset
next to [ __ ] amoeba records right if
you go into that one okay
they got a nice
nice
chicken applewood sausage
and the dude's half [ __ ] so he burns
it a little bit you catch the one
o'clock it's nice and fresh it's just a
little burnt yeah you tell mama boy
that's what you want
he puts in a bun he puts fresh onions on
it yeah a little mustard oh my god
and he gives it to him he wraps it up
you get one of those a diet soda maybe a
small popcorn who's better than you some
raisins
if you don't go to the movie theater you
don't have raising this you ain't real
you don't know you just wasted your time
and don't get me wrong again i go to the
movie theater i don't want to be beat
wait you get resonant every time
sometimes sometimes i switch it up yeah
yeah nine out of ten you gotta bust out
the raisin that's what he's doing and
the [ __ ] that sticks to your teeth it's
worth it
what's the numbers
and that's what's the ones that stick to
the yeah yeah oh those were good you
know why you don't like raising that's
cause nobody buys them so you sell them
when they're stale i was gonna get to
that [ __ ] you [ __ ] movie change
think you don't know i'm on to you but
i'm on to you [ __ ] okay you're
[ __ ] getting you're selling old
[ __ ] razor that's okay let me tell
you something i walk into a movie
theater in my i walk into a movie
theater like a hooker walks into a bar
you're talking about dots
yeah yeah yeah i take all the red ones
out and the the mixed fruit you know
what i love a taxi driver you ever see
that movie like he walks into the porno
theater and he buys like a royal crown
cola i love that rc car
popcorn juju's it's like a doll i don't
know what it was it was ridiculous
because it was in the 70s it was so
cheap but i love that scene where denier
was buying should get hungry but i get
the whole raisin that stands right
royal crown calls lately the raisin nets
have been stale that's my [ __ ] point
nick so in my mouth i walk in there like
a like a [ __ ] hooker walks into a bar
ready i got to taste the [ __ ] in my
mother
i have to taste the razor in my mouth
with chocolate [ __ ] just bring bring
the raisin that's with you and then
that's that you're right you're right i
mean bring away
a chunky bomb how about a good chunky
bar i love chocolate tasting i smoke two
or three joints you bust some of those
almond joys my way i love you to death
i'm enjoying it oh you bust out almond
joy i'll give you a hand job of the
movie
i'm into these [ __ ] seas candies
lately
nuts the nuts you're gonna buy the nuts
box the one with the nuts
nuts and something chews cheese candies
old school oh it's good
and you know chocolate is it's a good uh
you know gets you motivated that's what
i need in my life chocolate is good
believe me i don't like all that
chocolate around yeah
i told my wife to hide the kids
halloween truck i walk into the kitchen
one night storm to the gills
there's a box of halloween talking yeah
with miniature packages and [ __ ] and
there was two boxes but the one i bumped
into had those miniature [ __ ]
packages of m m's and [ __ ] uh peanut
ones
i destroyed the whole [ __ ] box oh my
god
i don't mix them that's disgusting no if
you put the peanut ones and the
chocolate ones in your mouth it's not a
bad idea that means you're double
chocking those [ __ ] yeah good
to see you there you too pal oh my
god a pleasure
look at that still up here still in the
[ __ ] game
still banging that throwing punches
i called him and asked him if he got one
in for an audition he went in he called
his agent
still [ __ ] this is it guys guys on
the street looking out and calls me just
hear about this it's no [ __ ] they're
not giving out no charity no more you
know there was a time when you walked
into the audition guys and you know you
know what i'm gonna get a call and they
call you and you went the next day and
got another chance to get this job yep
those days are over they've cut david
they've eliminated the middleman
completely first of all if you get the
uh
opportunity to go in you're blessed
because i gotta tell you something
while they're writing it and talking
about it they're already sending out an
offer to the guy i know that's the
[ __ ] problem now so
it's great that you got in on it when
you said that to me i was very happy
that you got in there a lot of guys
would just
wait for the phone to ring you gotta
attack everything you do that's why i
pick up the phone now and you got to be
proactive you're right and go in these
auditions and people are like man
you know i'm a fan of yours i love your
work i love you so it's nice that
everybody loves you but i'm like i'm
here just like you man i'm on the street
you know i've done a lot of things for
20 years got a big body of work but
i'm just like you man i'm just you know
i'm glad that you know still got plenty
of love on the street and respect but i
got to go in there and try to make it
happen but you know it's it's hard
because like you say there's always an
offer out or
uh you know you don't know the situation
or what they're gonna
i just booked one recently i was like
surprised i'm like wow i don't usually
get lucky with this auditioning stuff
was it's it's a whole other thing and
you know it's not you don't can't take
it personal
you know today i went and sometimes you
look at the list of names do you notice
anybody
you know you do but it's like it is what
it is
you know
it just changed a lot people it's it's
and i know these young people are going
out but you know what man you're a dad
you're a big baseball enthusiast you
really know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about
during the world series i was reading
your tweets
some of them you're writing the [ __ ]
money about what's going on you you have
a passion for [ __ ] sports
it's about time you got that
uh what's josh wolfe doing facetime you
gotta get a meeting with [ __ ]
facebook
and tell them you want your own show
they come to your house they set cameras
up for you they do it right there yeah
yeah you talk [ __ ] yeah right in front
of the camera that's what i need for
that yeah because i can i can have on my
own show while i'm watching a watching
the game talking about a game people
love being right and
listen to the hook yeah
everything you break is a sponsor so
this dish is brought to you by
super and also you smash it against the
wall
when they strike out a yankee at your
[ __ ]
people love that type of [ __ ] i'm saying
i'm an idea man i'm an idea man trust me
you're good you're good lee what's going
on in your world [ __ ] look at you
you're all excited you're packed
he's a little tiptoe in the house
tonight what time is your flight my
flight's at seven oh [ __ ] thirty that
means you gotta be up early we're gonna
take drop this little half hitter acid
just to get the blood going
so by the time we get to the airport
it's at the twilight zone and [ __ ]
with your luck they'll search you again
cause lately the dog's been on them
lately i don't know what it is about me
but the dog doesn't like me yeah i can't
wait
it's uh
it's a great time of year to go
because i can't dude i don't think you
understand and i the wilbur's so [ __ ]
cool i can't wait to go there like i
can't wait to go back there and see it
from a from like your perspective
i get to see my mom
it's uh why are you gonna give me
anxiety fully
oh why because i don't know it's my job
talking about your mother today that was
great yeah move me in the car and you
said
you know no matter how many years it is
there's nothing like mama
and that's why i tell people when you
get your parents alive
or your mother alive just you know i
didn't always maybe i didn't always
appreciate it
i feel her there but it's just never the
same you know
because
nobody can replace that nobody your wife
your girlfriend nobody gives you that
kind of love you know what i mean i mean
even me my brother wait sometimes i know
like i'm thinking about mommy and he's
like yeah
i'm thinking about it too it's that time
of year nick i said i know and the other
day he was reminiscing because remember
when we went to the willis reed show
marv albert was his co-host willis reed
had a show in the 70s remember that
nicholas i was like yeah yeah remember
when we went to the nick game and i was
teasing you with dave the busher against
rick barry because you love rick barry
you like to get under my skin you know
because the bushes was his man barry was
my man
you know you start thinking about your
reminiscence it's funny how you remember
all that [ __ ] when you were little and
you're young i remember nothing anymore
everything is a blur
my last 20 30 years a lot of [ __ ]
happened good bad i don't remember no i
remember [ __ ] when i was a kid i
remember baseball stuff for some reason
the baseball [ __ ] sticks in my head you
know you could say a certain player a
certain year and boom i remember that
guy it's funny how things you know like
everything becomes boom it went fast
almost 55 i'm like what the hell
happened my father used to go bam it
goes like that nicholas
it really does in the blink of an eye
you know i was just i thought i was just
30 or 40 in my 30s i was a king man i
was i was in my heyday i was on a hit
show a great show one of the best ever
and thinking man you know you just don't
realize how good it was every [ __ ]
day you have to stop for two minutes
the last
eight years i have stopped every day and
going wow
whether i had money in my pocket
no money in my pocket
i have stopped and said jesus christ you
know what the sad thing nick at our age
is
we refer to things now reality is 30
years ago
that's scary
lee you refer the thing as 10 years ago
you're 28 years old that's scary 10
years ago you were 18.
you referred a thing 20 you remember mom
and dad 20 years ago
you took me roller skating yeah on my
knee oh my god you know but
for nick now when i speak to people you
talk to them in the 30-year range
this [ __ ] you remember yeah i talk to
people from time to time i went home
two months ago and i went up to a bar
and i met some people from
mckinley where i went to grammar school
that
and then one girl told me a story that i
remembered but i didn't remember
but she confirmed what i didn't remember
you i'm saying like you get [ __ ] like
that from time to time yeah that's very
interesting when somebody goes remember
nick
we went up there and i'm like yeah who
was with us nick
this guy this guy
jimmy you're like jimmy fat yes he was
remember he drove the car and you're
like oh [ __ ] yeah that's right we stole
his father's car
you know and you really uh
i refer to things as 30 years ago and i
got to tell you man if you listen i know
we have all ages 30 years goes by
[ __ ] fast
i listen to this music i listen to
this [ __ ] [ __ ] music i listen to we
were just watching something
10 minutes ago that was 45 years old
that
still sounds fantastic but the reality
of it that if there were 10 musicians on
the stage
eight and a half of them are dead
they were in their 40s they were in
their prime you don't know
just don't know how quick the ride is i
remember when i first got on blue people
were telling me
enjoy the ride i mean i was just hoping
not last one year i wasn't thinking just
enjoy the ride enjoy the ride kid
and i was like i didn't know what they
meant
but you know if you could just slow it
down sometimes you could just [ __ ]
slow it down for a second
and just go oh man this is
this is really something but then you
know you settle in and life changes and
you change and you get caught up in [ __ ]
you got people around you i had like an
entourage
all kinds of people i'm attending to and
and i'm thinking you know you think
you're you're tarzan but
you're not man and it goes fast
a lot it was exciting
it was never boring
you know even like the longer you look
back the longest yard that was
that was 11 you know 11 years ago
you're like wow i remember that you know
we shot that in 2004.
lee think of that number how old were
you in 2004
you were 16 years old
yeah oh my god did they come out in the
summer
it came out in may
we shot it in the summer okay so came
out may of what 2000 2005.
what a blessing came out you were 17. 17
man yeah wow but think about it you were
16 when we shot this [ __ ] movie you
know i saw a post i was in tarzana
that they were going to make the longest
there was a poster and an early poster
right
remember it said it said adam's name on
it or burt reynolds but it was like a
guy was like handcuffs right and there
was the handcuffs yeah against guys and
no handcuffs on and i said
oh i gotta look into that movie that's a
movie that's being made that's when i
first
saw it and thought about it
because i didn't i didn't know adam i
didn't know him i mean
and that's that's when it gave me the
idea but i wasn't that familiar with the
original movie but i always loved burt
reynolds
the original movie i love is actually
great i love it i mean the kids i i
gotta be honest the original movie
i used to go to the same movie theater
to watch it's a good movie
from time to time my godfather when i
lived in new york city
well in the 8th street he would take me
to 42nd street and that's why i watched
dirty harry and uh wow
the velocity papers pelanchi papers i
watched the love bug there i watched uh
the strongest man in the world there
but once my mom moved to jersey i
started going to this place called
encinema
it was a spanish italian movie plays
popcorn chocolate razor nuts
i could smell it right now as i'm
describing it till you had the
the pale color with like the burgundy
trimmings all around and burgundy
curtains and once you pass the ticket
hole there was every man from zelda were
they wearing like the white shirts with
you know i don't remember their outfits
lee i remember the the candy concession
was to the right-hand side and there was
just one movie theater it was a huge
special and it was broken into three
areas so you had the lower the middle
and the back right and i went to see
i mean there's a collection of films i
went to see i went to see the [ __ ]
exorcist there in the afternoon that's
when they didn't give a [ __ ] how of all
you were that was a hard one to get into
if you had a dominant quarter to get in
we don't know nothing you know what i'm
saying if the cops come we don't know
nothing
and uh i want to see the exorcist there
i went to see enter the dragon there wow
i went to see the chinese connection
yeah
they have double features
remember when they used to have double
and triple that time when bruce lee hit
with the chinese connection then they
started doing chinese connection and
fist of fury just a fury for a dollar 25
and you went in there and stayed there
all [ __ ] night you know you were
there for six hours because they played
right they just played there was no
intermission i think the one
intermission they swept but after that
it went straight to 1am you know
and on the right hand side was the
concession and you went in there
but the two movie i went to see tommy
there
with the two movies that stick out in my
mind in that place
that i really thought the rest of my
life movie theaters are going to be like
that wasn't one rocky
the place went bad yeah the whole movie
theater was on their feet
and two
the longest yard at the end oh really
the whole place is young so you saw that
in the big screen i saw that in a big
screen at a movie theater in union city
new jersey wow
1973 now weird never knowing that you
would be in you know not it no no that
wasn't people let me in in your mind
never in my [ __ ] thought
and then i saw the longest yard again
years later the the original
i saw it again like
10 years later right before i got locked
up
i was living nah i was living in uh hey
i was living in aspen colorado and i
worked at a movie video rental place and
then i would order movies and i was like
where's the charles bronson section
and the guy's like we really don't rent
charles bronson are you [ __ ] crazy
i went and got stone killer the mechanic
mechanic uh
that was the death wish the one with the
watermelons
when they took these watermelons i got i
got like four or five of them
and people were just renting them all
the time and i would take them whenever
i didn't rent i'd take it home even
though if i had watched it
i'd take it home so i was a big charles
brown your man huh yeah that was my main
match bronson i'm a [ __ ] uh
coburn dude i like those that error
i got [ __ ] allergies or something i'm
really happy there are some video
stories coming back i have missed my
video stores
it was it was it was a
an amazing place
as a kid especially as a nerd
just getting there because because we
couldn't get there i didn't have buses
or anything like that
i could only go if my mom took us
and it was it was it was amazing i was
so sad when i closed
i was a movie buff growing up you know
what i mean john used to do he used to
go to a place called stephen sally's
in new york
and we used to buy
lobby cards and movie pictures you could
go to this place and buy
actual prints from kirk douglas movies
burt lancaster we loved all old movies
beautiful you know the lobby cards and
and the black and these are beautiful
prints we used to buy all these you guys
still around steven sally's you can go
to shows and buy these kinds of pictures
and stuff but people don't only nut nuts
that you know do that kind of stuff they
were special you know i used to put them
in our room
oh wow look at this
lonely all the brave
kirk douglas or
you know the swimmer burt lanky we had
all these movies that we love we were we
were like movie critics in my family
you know we used to like
who knew we were going to be in the
movies but we kind of like lived through
the movie spartacus
alma gantry all these great movies
great movies i mean you watch these
movies today
yeah you lived yeah it was a different
experience but the longest shot my god
that was a good i mean that was really a
good movie
so when your son goes to the movie
theaters what does it cost him right now
at his age oh with him with just what by
himself yeah
it cost him
like 30 bucks maybe
yeah every time he buys something to
drink and eat and a movie ticket
and if he goes to the arc light it's
more money because the amc maybe it's a
little less
wow
yeah wow and the thing that kills me and
uh everything give me the boss to the
movie it's the same price they're more
they're a little bit higher boston is
higher a little bit probably
like probably a little bit out yes yeah
this is guys 15 or 16. let me look at
that
how long does it take americans to go
wait a second you know what
we've been doing this a certain way
i mean i think we i think they are with
like the internet i think i think that's
what's happening
i think that's why like this the market
was crashing yeah
that's why it's hard to sell movies man
was the market really crashing
i i don't i don't know anything about
stock i just heard
that they dropped a coupon points
what's going on
i don't know
i'm not gonna take your prices
let's see
hysterical
okay never mind boston's not that bad
how much is boss 13.99
at night
so what is that
13
and that's not that's not 3d or anything
i'm [ __ ] believable ladies and
gentlemen
every day you learn something [ __ ]
new
you know when this guy like i said
this is what got me going and i don't
even vote i have no interest in it
when this whole thing started
i thought it would last 90 [ __ ] days
that's it and no no no i didn't think it
would last 90 days i'm very sorry it
took him 90 days to hang himself
oh you think yeah i'm saying
at first he was talking some sense
then it took him 90 [ __ ] days right
to hang himself right but she you know
they just don't want to rent at those
places
somebody was saying that the unions
didn't want to you know
uh
listen we need something new i don't
know if this guy's the answer i don't
know bernie sanders would have been the
answer
i don't know anymore do you what was the
reaction when reagan was elected because
i know he's loved now
but he was an actor but i know he yeah
but he because he was coming right he
was governor first yeah he had some
he had polished himself a little bit you
know when all that stuff was going on
i was so [ __ ] high i was young
i didn't give a [ __ ] about that stuff
growing up it didn't even
by that time i was done with it i had
seen some [ __ ] in jersey i was like god
and new york
new york city at that time
you know people talking about play to
pay
that's been going on for 30 [ __ ]
thousand million years you think clinton
was the first person to do some faces
look at the faces
of what just people outside like looking
look at that
jesus constance
i mean
jesus
i was i was thinking about this earlier
but we left the topic but
was there ever a president
that
didn't like like came through with a lot
of the things that they promised
everything that i've noticed i've only
been through a few presidents
and no one's ever come through with
anything
so i i've kind of checked out
a presidential election was clinton good
nick
bill yeah
yeah he was pretty good bill actually
was pretty good for a while and um
i thought he was doing
country was i mean you know in the end
there were things that came out but
overall i think clinton was a pretty
good president
you know i mean he's a smart guy i mean
she helped make him
she's a bright lady but
she doesn't have what he has you know
he just had that he had the complete
you know what i mean he had the complete
package and he was likable people loved
him they liked him
just like obama people like obama
this is a whole other thing i don't know
this is a weird night
this is a string doesn't it feel weird i
mean i mean like you said the sun's
going to rise but
i ate 10 stars i don't know nothing
hey the cubs won 180 years my wife has
half an hour of robbie island that
refrigerator the baseball gods came out
that's going to be haunting me and [ __ ]
felipe
felipe sparser was the tweet of the
night he said hillary clinton fans
look like chicago cub fans after the
fourth game
i was just [ __ ] around i thought i
always thought trump was going to get a
big vote amount
i thought at the end hillary would
polish him off i think she still has a
shot at this moment as we're speaking um
hopefully you know hopefully she'll pull
it out i mean uh
so people don't you know jump off the
bridge
but uh i didn't think it would be like
this again i don't know anything about
[ __ ] politics me neither my wife
talks to her mom and dad they giggle her
mom and dad
and uh that's as far as politics as i
listen to you know it brings out a lot
of stuff politics you have conversations
with people
and it just gets it turns ugly it gets
nasty on all that's what i don't like
about it
and what these people should do is work
together
as well the politics ruins it you know
it's like instead of working together
it's always about who can cut who up and
who's got the angle that's what i don't
get about
politicians or politics you ask one side
one thing they say that then the other
side says this so then you go
what do i believe
what do i believe
you know the truth lies somewhere
we have to attack also
see when i come to you
and i go well councilman tutorial uh
joey coco diaz i'm part of the
recreation department and listen we need
some funding
for an acting program and you're like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about i'm
like listen
i got 22 kids over there they love
brando
they love pacino
they love jimmy schmitz all right and
what they want to do is they want to
learn how to act
they will cost you peanuts
plus there's 20 kids
they're two parents a piece
everybody knows when you die you get 250
mass cards everybody at least knows 250
people
do you want people to know councilman
tutor that you didn't give us the acting
program after you went how would that
feel in your community okay what can you
do for me get me signatures for this
puppy
and we work together and i hold you to
your promises
right a lot of people give up or he
won't do it no hold him to his [ __ ]
promise
hold him how do you hold him through a
promise voters
he doesn't want to lose those people
once you get in there next to toronto
that's an it's not the first time when
you start stealing
it's the second time you see the first
term you set the tunnels up right i'm
gonna rob this guy i'm gonna rub this
guy there's a mall opening up it's a no
zone mall
you know what i'm saying it's a 20
million dollar job two million i gotta
go in my pocket directly
oh he ain't opening no [ __ ] mall you
follow me i mean lee it's so dirty
you sit there you know look at the
this guy from jersey i'll give you an
example
look at this guy from jersey
to close the [ __ ] bridge i don't even
live in jersey but i know how it works
as soon as i heard it i go wait a second
what kills me about it he's letting a
woman go to jail
christy yeah
that's just i don't really know the
facts but she's got four kids christy
go in there tell the truth
let the girl get probation through a lot
of politics let it let them take a law
degree away
but don't let a mother of four
get sent to [ __ ] prison
you know this is what's going on you
know listen
when i'm the governor i got three or
four guys those three or four guys you
get paid to insulate me okay
what does that mean
if i'm with a hooker and i stab her in
the throat
guess who's taking her to the swamps
getting ready
you're taking a body to the swamps he's
done this before
lee how many bodies we bury out there 18
19 yes sir one buddy because libra
because lee believes i'm gonna be
president united states someday and he's
gonna be my number one god guys he told
his father already he's gonna be the
first jewish whatever
so it becomes cultish
it becomes kind of cultish in a way like
yes sir right you're doing [ __ ] for this
guy that
he kills somebody in that condo who do
you think buries him out in [ __ ]
jersey city exactly you and lee that's
your new job you just take care of dead
hookers
you pull the teeth you throw a lie on
them you cut off the fingertips bring it
back to me at least done it before
rightly
absolutely it's like that movie with the
with burt reynolds when he plays the
congressman or whatever and demi moore's
a strip when he's in love with it and he
hires the guy to take the lint
from her uh
from her laundry and he would he would
grant me bro
you ever see the movie league no no no
you haven't because you're a [ __ ]
mobo
you know
what's the name of that there's a movie
that is hilarious
but rather than it's way i think it's
before boogie nights i'm not sure don't
quote me on this
but they play
burt reynolds look that up lee look that
up william wasn't remember he plays a
governor with demi moore
and somebody else
it's uh
1997.
she plays a stripper
oh striptease and
yes
is that funny
watch this see him
typing burt reynolds strip teasely see
if it comes up
well what this guy did was
he rubbed butter on himself he put a
cowboy hat on and cowboy boots
and they would bring him the lint from
the laundry and he would just whack off
really yeah but they you know listen you
just don't come up with that
somebody's had to do that in front of
you at least one time in your life you
gotta look at that and go you know the
senate is great meanwhile you call them
a cowboy boots with butter all over them
cause those guys become [ __ ] congress
[ __ ] just to be freaks
yeah those are the people that [ __ ] it
that's true
it's sad but i know you know my one's a
doorman had a cowboy one time like that
asked me to come up the room he answered
in his underwear and cowboy hat and
boots
i said what do you need sir he said you
do just fine
i said i don't know what to say i was
the doorman
he goes
i don't know why how was it i was in my
20s how old was he it's all you know man
50 or something
i had no idea that he wanted to swing
that way but he had made me laugh with
the cowboy boots anything in the butter
using his underwear it was a sight to
see i said you know what i said i'll
i'll get back to you he had butter on
himself no i'm saying imagine if he had
butter oh that's [ __ ] crazy
i had to get out of there when i was a
doorman i experienced
a lot
a lot of stuff
oh my god you find anything from the
stream like a two second clip that's a
lot going on don't worry about it
that's a good that's a you know i gotta
watch that that's a great movie that's
not it's not an academy award winner but
for that time period brett reynolds
you know brett reynolds disappeared for
a while he had tax problems
he stabbed somebody you know brent had
some problems a wow guy then he came
back with striptease
the other one boogie nights
he was outstanding he's great and he
went straight from there so
man he blew me away and boogie he was so
good in that
i love that one scene where wahlberg
he's good mark wahlberg and he uh
he comes out he's like you know he
couldn't get a hot on
and he's in the bathroom and they got
this other new kid out there like johnny
wadd you know i don't know where they
found him and and wahlberg was like
you're not an actor you're not an actor
i'm an actor not you you know so he was
like trying to get hard and then he
tells bert
bert knew he was coked up and he goes
i'm ready i'm ready i'm ready to [ __ ]
i'm ready to [ __ ] right now he's like no
you're not ready let's get out of here
he goes i got the biggest dick here
and burp medals like grab somebody
that's wrote he goes you're fired
and he goes [ __ ] you man he like goes
into a karate stance like bruce lee man
it was a great scene it really is i mean
a great scene
what a great movie funny and sad
oh man that movie is
dynamite or paul thomas anderson
i'm a big fan of his
that movie is a is a really emotional
that's a that that movie roller coaster
rider you've never seen boogie nights
you better smoke a number and and get a
blanket and really focus on what goes on
there right
they take you on a [ __ ] ride their
scenes and that brilliant
that you look at and go jesus
one thought of this [ __ ] i know what the
guy's watching his wife
you know get you know what's his name
what's his name the guy with the forget
his name he's a good actor he shoots
himself he shoots himself man
macy mason macy what how about phil
seymour yeah he's in oh my god he's
great monkey wahlberg was understood
wallberg
reynolds goes to the jail
to see the guy that molested the little
boys and the producers
behind the glass the captain yeah he's
like they found pictures did you do it
did you do it because they're so
innocent i just love to they sit on my
lap i don't ever do anything that's when
bird had to like walk away from yeah
don't leave me roll the girl how about
that scene in the car with the
the girl and are they pulling heather
what's her name heather
what's her name the actress she was oh
man pulls them off i i like to say it's
ventura but it's not it's not really
ventura boulevard it's supposed to be is
it really well because the guy grew up
in the valley you know she pulls up next
to him and they asked her to get her
yeah they make her fam and he got rough
with her they start making out and she's
like relax and [ __ ] you it's a shame you
turned out to become this
and he's got makeup on his face and he's
just what did you say right that's right
you became a [ __ ] loser
and then he goes out as he's putting his
jacket on she goes out of the car and
clocks him with something
he goes down they start kicking him and
[ __ ] yeah there's [ __ ] blood
everywhere at the same time they're
mixing in the scene
with marky wahlberg in a parking lot and
a little guy in the truck pulls up next
to him yeah and they're asking each
other what do you want to do i don't
know what do you want to do what do you
want to do he goes i'm going to see you
work jerk off
ten bucks
10 bucks right at the same time this
scene's going on
and mikey and then all of a sudden you
go back to the scene which she's still
kicking them with the roller skates on
and blood's going everywhere then you go
back to the scene where marky wahlberg
is jerking the [ __ ] off and all of a
sudden she goes back to the scene where
reynolds comes out and they have an
argument now and reynolds starts
punching this [ __ ] he loses it
and back to the scene where [ __ ] all
of a sudden a truck full of guys pull up
get out and beat the [ __ ] out of the
wall beat the [ __ ] out of marquee what
about the scene with the molina that is
whack then it takes you to another scene
now they're so hooked it really takes
you to a sad um
it takes you to a sad view
of what happened at that time period
with cocaine how quick
it got into the game
and changed
everything
it changed
everything it changed these people
completely you see it anybody who does a
movie about the 80s
and shows anybody could show you coke
but to see the transformation of people
where it took him that's when yeah
henry hill
scorsese was the first one who did it
when he snorts the coke and pops up and
they show his face his nose getting red
right at his eyes they focus on his eyes
getting dilated that's beautiful right
his eyes were funny what i'm saying like
all that stuff is beautiful well you saw
it it would wall i mean the
transformation oh real quick yeah
because
he was an innocent he was kind of like
he was vulnerable and he was innocent
even though he was a dishwasher or a
waiver he was like uh
oh yeah he was not even a waiter who's a
what do they call that the bus boy he
was a bus boy you know he had the poppy
hairdo and
um you know even then the mother who was
like freaking out where you going at
night where you going
you know he was like i'm gonna be a star
i'm gonna be a star he had the pictures
i mean he like he wanted to be somebody
you know and and he was he was he
believed he was really like he took it
serious
that he was this porno star you know he
really like he thought he was doing some
good acting you know was very good and
that's a black kid he's big now oh he's
a good actor he goes into the donut
place yeah he robbed the place and he
gets the money open up a stereo shop a
very good actor
there's so many different stories a lot
going on
and they're all very uh it's a great
more every part of it
when you watch the movie and if you're
watching it you have control of it you
won't speed through those scenes no
because then that every scene comes
together
the movie comes together great where him
at the end he shows his big dick yeah
it's a rubber thing and people went nuts
you ever watch it lee
it's a must
why would you that's the first thing i
do when i go to tonight when you get
home at two in the morning
wake paul up and watch boogie nights
i like that movie you know you know
why'd you tell me all the crazy horrible
scenes yeah but you still gotta see it
you know it's funny too
it's funny it's very entertaining it's
also sad and very sad in a lot of ways
then they have a story with the chick
she can't see your kids yeah but there's
a scene in that movie where her and
heather are locked in the room and
they've been in there for about eight
hours
and they're snorting coke
and they're talking to each other she's
like why won't you be my mommy okay from
now on i'll be your mommy okay you're my
mommy you're my mommy let's go for a
walking shoes no let's not go for a walk
dog
unless you've been up for 10 hours on
blow
that's exactly how people act he nailed
it huh when you're locked in a room with
something on an apartment with somebody
eight ten hours
you start [ __ ] getting crazy
you start talking you know nick i've
always loved you since the time we did
the longest really joey i love you too
like a brother and son jesus christ
let's do another line okay
you know it's all part of the [ __ ]
stupidity right but it becomes something
else you know and then you go for 20
hours
and it becomes something completely
[ __ ] different it's such a sort of
really show
i can always tell when the movie's
faking the [ __ ] yeah you know when they
put coke on the table okay anybody could
do that's that's a that's a ten dollar
[ __ ] stunt right right you could that
could be anything white i don't know
what that is
it's the feeling that the director
gives you one of the best is scorsese
um
scarface yeah
if it wasn't even the shots i think it
was more the music
the music scared you into the cocaine it
was like evil music yeah the music was
great
i know the organs came in strong that's
all they needed
was every time they showed coke was to
make what's his name go ah
and nobody would have done coke no more
he said he [ __ ] up
lee what's going on over there what did
uma thurman
almost odeon
was that coke or is it heroin
it was heroin because she was looking
for coke
but instead travalta had coke and heroin
he bought from that dealer
what's that thing they did to her they
like gave her a shock they gave her a
shot of that and adrenaline right
traveling oh that listen that's the part
i fainted
really listen the first time i went to
see that movie
first time that movie came out what
94.95
okay
pulp fiction that is right mm-hmm
i was living in boulder colorado
had friends i had 94.
had friends i had a life
i was in a terrible position with my
ex-wife but i had these little goombas
around the delhi the delhi zone and
they had front girls that they hung out
with they were
they were kids
they were 24 and here i am a loser
comedian
32
i know child support and [ __ ] but these
guys were my friends i had a car i had a
bicycle for days and i didn't have cash
you know
i was just trying to put the pieces
together man and uh
one night they invite me like a listen
we bought like 15 tickets you might go
see this new tarantino movie they're
telling me where this guy is like all
right let's go
and i'm having a great [ __ ] time
you're not going to believe this story
when i tell you jesus christ
i don't even want to [ __ ] tell you
because you're gonna be mad at me
so i'm just gonna substitute it for the
sake but it really was
i'm sitting there having a great time
it's a bunch of us sitting together you
know like when you all your friends get
to sit together
and it comes to that part
where he shoves the needle on her heart
and i pass out
just like right now crammed and going
out out out no noise no
no noise no nothing i went my head went
back and i just rolled off the chair a
little bit and after about a minute they
realized
check on joey what's going on there
and then checked on me and [ __ ] they
threw a little water in my face and [ __ ]
when i woke up i heard you know
a little bit of that [ __ ] and then i
realized my faith and you know what
happened i go
i fainted when i saw the the blood go in
there
but how i came out of that
i popped the [ __ ] razor that
and his head took
go [ __ ] yourself
you like chicken you like chocolates or
peanuts yeah peanut m
what are you talking about
listen dawg
i like having lemons too the [ __ ] is
w-y-a what does that mean lee
w-i-n my son sends me that w-y-a don't
even tell me trump won because people
call that travel agent as you speak is
that what that means oh [ __ ] i'll go to
cnn all right right now [ __ ] let me
tell you something if trump wins tonight
there's gonna be a trump code get out uh
trump surges
oh my god he's winning 244 to 215. is he
losing he's winning oh my god
he will when you talk
people they project
oh my god you heard it [ __ ] well
you know by the time you hit the podcast
by the time you hear this you'll be the
old news right it'll be old news you'll
be sitting there going what the [ __ ]
happened last night
who knows who knew you didn't really
know i i had a feeling i didn't know
you know the phone calls did not phone
calls the foundation
i think i didn't know that it lied a lot
deeper than that that's how uninformed i
was so
who the [ __ ] gives this [ __ ] good to see
you nick
i love you what was the last thing you
shot
i shot uh this movie called a chance in
the world in chicago
got a little movie that just came out
now uh called subterranea that i did
like two years ago it just
came out on you know dvd it's a
weird little [ __ ] movie not bad then
something called the eyes which is
coming out and all these indies i'm the
king of indies right now
but trying to shoot my own pilot which i
want you to be a part of
so um you know just forging ahead trying
to stay alive
trying to stay alive joe
i'm sorry about that i'm still getting a
lot of anxiety from those stars
you're right
oh yeah i'm always fine i just make me
worry when i want to watch you i hear
you breathing i'm like i just got to get
my composure yeah
i got the nose done not for beauty sake
oh it's better than you could do it to
breathe
yeah to breathe but lately i've been
getting clogged up again and i've been
getting a headache on the right side of
my head sinus so something's going
[ __ ] on if this goes on
if i wake up tonight with a headache
tomorrow i gotta wake up later and go
right to the dock
you might need an mri check it out yeah
something something's not right i'm not
getting dizzy spells i've been going
where's the headache
right here
up there yeah
and you're waking up with it or yeah i
wake up at one in the morning when i go
to pee two in the morning
i got a [ __ ] headache
well you gotta just check it out
i mean watch with those stars maybe too
many stars no i'll be on the lookout for
stars i don't want somebody gonna break
the monotony i've been getting
i run up in a good boy lately except for
saturday night like the double package
of that death good i'm trying probably
look good i'm trying the special looks
great
you know man 25 [ __ ] years of doing
comedy deserve it yeah no i'm very happy
funny bastard i'm really happy with it
i'm really happy they gave me a shot so
here we are
it comes out december 8th on cso
it's a division of nbc
right now nbc has a ton of great stuff
on there so a lot of people know about
see so a lot of them don't
where is cso now how do i find that how
do they find that way
cecil it's on it's everywhere i have i
have mine on my uh amazon prime in my
roku it's great so um
actually what are they buying these
people
so
there's a streaming service i want to
stream on them and let me see if i can
find a list of the devices
so the oh my god it's everywhere so you
can do it on your desktop
your mobile android amazon fire ios
every all of them and tablets
you can do your roku
amazon xbox windows 10 chromecast apps
and if you have an apple tv you can
airplay from your mobile device or
desktop computer awesome so it's from
everywhere let's say you have a big
screen tv like this can you plug it into
your computer it'll play up there
you could but your big screen tv
probably has it could either even be a
smart tv and have the app or you could
have a roku so you don't even you might
not even need that you're [ __ ]
geniusly so if you don't have it you
know what you do you're gonna see so
impressed
well you got to be prepared i was
prepared
when is it going to air december 8th it
is
december 8th
very good you've been cooking lately
yeah i've been making some sauce
in fact i'm thinking of reviving my
sauce because
i had it in a jar
years ago and these italians just
got into a lot of trouble we didn't have
any capital
so i got a guy that called me the other
day from st louis he goes hey
remember that sauce you made in the jar
nicky red sauce i said yeah cause it was
a great sauce i got this company up in
oregon
they're packers
they may want to pack it and do the
whole thing
oh my god this nick nick he's probably
calling me about trump
um so i called the guy that made the
sauce
and uh he says listen nick
i'll help you out because if you want
i'll give you the recipe because it took
me a while to make it right for you
because it came out great i just need
capital so maybe we'll get it going and
we'll call it nikki red source from the
tutorial brothers i bring johnny into it
that'll help me you know nick and john
even though john's got nothing to do
with the sauce
but i make a mean you know
sausage red sauce you know i'd say just
one kind just one no well we had one
flavor but we got to make more than one
flavor to be seen on the shelves you
need like five six flavors but from the
base sauce they could make other flavors
yeah you can make a you know a roasted
garlic yeah roasted garlic you can make
basil you can make you know
the main meat sauce which i made with
pork rib bones that comes out came out
fantastic
i'll show you a picture the other dad
i put some meatballs together
tremendous
she thinks i'm like falling around this
late you see what i mean
yeah
it goes on for hours
yeah
that's right
what are you gonna do you're never out
past [ __ ] 8 30 at night
you're sitting on your couch yelling at
the tv tweeting right go [ __ ] you read
my all my tweets always my son goes all
you talk about is baseball pitching
right yeah i know this guy's crazy
the world series was a great i don't
have to spoke about it i'm analyzing
i'm analyzing it hey man it should look
get off that phone let's finish this
[ __ ] i know if that will i'll never get
your attention and [ __ ] like i haven't
seen you in years where the [ __ ] you
been i went away i know i've been away a
long time nobody went up in there and
told you right
and now we're back
you're still shining shoes i was trying
to shoot nobody i don't shine shoes
anymore that's right nobody went up
there i'll tell
all of a sudden why are you getting
fresh
i wonder if he's still one people yeah
oh
that can do it frank vincent yeah yeah i
think he's alive i think he had
i think he had some uh some issues you
know i heard he was sick a little bit
but he always had a great head of hair
he had that nice gray hair i worked with
him on uh
jungle fever with spike and then he was
in witness to the mob with me
and then you know he did the sopranos he
did uh
he always had a great phrase face that
frank vincent you know i'm gonna do the
right thing when he's going through the
uh
the fire hydrant what's the guy's name
johnny black johnny who yeah yeah joe
black
joe joe
joe black joe right i don't [ __ ] know
he is he went crazy philippe was here
the other day oh i suppose yeah we were
talking about your movie when you were
kind enough
to give us both roles oh that movie was
a disaster but i gave you guys parts
but the funniest thing in the world you
know we gave david pro val weed oh my
you guys gave him weed
he's a great actor that's why one of the
days he was forgetting his lines
and his following day off
he went and got a medical marijuana
license and he's never looked back
i bumped into him three years later he's
like listen dog you saved my life i was
having a lot of problems and [ __ ]
you gave me that pot cookie i went home
and slept for 18 hours but when i woke
up my problems were healed
i tell you about david praval that guy
he [ __ ] him up on the set he fell over
one time on a chair and hit his head on
the movie set yeah and then he goes
that little filipino producer was an
animal nick an ice woman i said i know
she was a cold and i wound up having
fights with those two
people because they they were [ __ ]
they just they were like
really animals and i
you know they wanted to make a movie and
the thing was
really all over the place and i
and then they brought these other guys
in i brought a director in that he had
an ask off he didn't know what the [ __ ]
he didn't know what he was talking about
i wanted to fire him and i brought him
in
i brought him in i wanted to fire him
as soon as you saw this guy no this
[ __ ] guy i didn't know he was a real
move and i almost killed him i threw him
out of the editing room
i went to the editing room and i said
get out
get the [ __ ] out he was like what what
what what i said i got final cut now
take a [ __ ] walk
you and your [ __ ] ask off go get out
of here it's the worst yeah one time he
he did something the kids were acting my
son was acting and and he like told him
like i said what are you doing don't
don't call cut
these are kids the behavior is beautiful
what are you doing he knew nothing about
acting this guy he like lived in a you
know i i didn't know him and i just
brought him in because i thought i did
this little movie this guy had a bad
piece it was like oh my god
guy i was like a horrible hairpiece i
was gonna take his head
and take the dp's head and like together
i was gonna crunch both of them oh you
have no idea people at home i mean you
know you do all kinds of movies it was
classic this was the only problem we
didn't do with this
was shooting the documentary we should
have that's where the moment that's
where the money would have been because
the making of that movie a lot of people
joey's in it at paul rodriguez his
[ __ ] felipe came he had a [ __ ] wig
piece and it was uh
that [ __ ] ask off like he was from
like some he was some uh english like
indian guy he was trying to sound
interesting
i
they shot me and then i had to go for an
audition i shaved my mustache
so that'll paint them
probably gave you a really shitty
mustache
joey was a sheriff oh my god there's
some funny [ __ ] in it
but you know it is what it is but you're
right the making of that movie would
have been genius the movie forget about
it yeah that movie was forgetting making
oven paul rodriguez was four hours late
and they sent somebody over to his house
oh my god break the fence and wake him
up and [ __ ] oh we were laughing about
that i only did it for the money you
know my wife told me don don't do this
don't work with that guy
don't work with that guy because he was
a father at the school and he was
chasing me and he gave me a script i
said it's unreadable i don't know what
to do with that when you try to rewrite
a bad script it was it was rough and
then i brought that guy in with the with
the hair and
that was a bad choice then i wanted to
get rid of him and then the other guy
wouldn't fire him you know the producer
he was like no no
i said
it's either him or me i said i was
getting mad i was getting really angry
i wanted i wound up i didn't want to be
mean to the guy because i brought him in
but then i threw him out of the editing
room that was the funniest when i saw
him in the editing room i was like get
out you know you have to [ __ ] leave
now i said because i got to try to save
it i couldn't really save it
i came to this town in 1997
and within six months i was booked for
something
if you want me to lie to you i didn't
know what i was doing this went on for a
few years i didn't know what i was doing
i finally got into an acting class and
got the basics and i didn't know what i
was doing and then guys by 2000 i
started working and working and working
and working and it was always something
a tv show mad tv a movie
back to a tv show guess our co-star
i did 10 [ __ ] co-stars you know what
a co-star is two and a half lines if
you're lucky me i know how to squeeze an
extra line on a [ __ ] anything
i know how to break two lines in half
i'm the king of all that [ __ ] so i'll at
least get four lines but i get four or
five hours in the set i get to eat like
a king i don't get to take a sandwich
home talk to somebody i've never met
before
but it's funny that at this point in my
life
if i had a gun to my head
and you gave me time not money
i could direct the phone oh yeah do you
follow me just from the experience i've
had sure well joey you never went to a
director school listen i've watched ten
thousand movies i know what i like i
don't know what i don't know what you
don't like i know the cuts i'm looking
for i know what to give the viewer right
and this is how this movie has to get
done exactly these movies today they
give you everything when i was growing
up i grew up on films that left you
hanging mentally
and all sudden your mental state started
asking for it the reason why and i
repeat myself they never showed the body
of don corleone
they only show the curtain blowing with
the wind they never zero one on them to
show them dead they never do
they give you a tone from a side vision
just cuts like that that you have to go
home and think about and go why didn't
they show them lying there like
everybody else right
and you know that's that's knowing what
you're looking at too and then i even
when he was pushing me he was why don't
you do i i just figured well at the time
i don't want to be bob well i'll bring
someone in like you know like you know
adam has these guys come in but adam's
sort of in charge but this guy was
trying to be autistic with an ask off
and i was just like peeing in my pants i
said i got to throw him like i wanted to
throw him over the hill i wanted to like
get him right in that ranch and leave
him there but you know but he wasn't a
bad guy just but you're right if you if
you know
what good acting is if you know if you
have a had a vision and you know how to
tell a story you you don't have to be a
genius you just have to have good people
around you
like this guy wouldn't have a clue what
was good he didn't know what he was
looking at it's like a lot of tv guys
you know sometimes they're just traffic
cops they're not artists sometimes you
work with some guys that'll actually
work with you with the performance
they'll fine-tune it with you and you go
okay this guy is good he's not just
putting his cameras everywhere not just
sticking a camera
it's it's about you know
having a
you know relationship knowing how to
talk to an actor knowing how to get a
performance out of a guy
that's what it's about
those are some beautiful [ __ ] words
brother
good luck the cop sirens are starting
already yeah it's not afraid man what
are you afraid of nothing's going to
happen
to you
lori ortega uncle joey loves you
stu munoz heidi geldis young
russ from boston
brian o'shea
mike
james strickland you know i love you
[ __ ] with all my heart you bad
sorry for that lady i hope everybody you
know listen man i'm always optimistic
like i said
they tried to scam me like two or three
elections
and i realized that uh as an american
the the beauty about being an american
is that you're raised
to keep on going
they're going to take more taxes joey
listen
it's a cost for making money taxes i
don't want you to think about taxes is
not paying them
because you don't want to pay them i
want you to think about them as paying
them because you're making the money to
pay them and that eliminates that whole
thing
everybody in this room when they get
their tax bill
at the end of the year
your [ __ ] jaw jobs yeah your jaw
drops you can't [ __ ] believe it you
were a kid a couple years ago you paid
35 dollars
you marked off check and they gave you
all your [ __ ] federal and [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying what about what
about when you're coming out of college
and and you have all these loans and
you're like okay i'm making 500 a week
and they're expecting 1500 or something
and then it comes back and it's i don't
know what what what would it be
12 something
so three something 13 something
it's uh
it's killer month to month but yeah when
you have a pair at once at the end of
the years
it's scary
i think i finally might be able
to pay it off without credit cards
i hope that
i remember being in a hole
at a certain age
like i was in a hole
for years but it didn't really matter i
was in the hole
but then i got involved in a
relationship and i had a child
and after i got separated from her
i got into a hole and i remember you
know me though i just told you
i keep records of every audition i went
at
i got into a hole that
every time i would redo my paperwork i
get more and more depressed
because i didn't know about that world
the world i came from you did something
you paid for when i was growing up i
[ __ ] drug dealers over and bookies and
[ __ ] like that
i'm not talking about that stuff
for some
reason
one day i go somewhere
and somebody says to me joe diaz you
have great credit
this is after years of being a [ __ ]
abandoned next detail
and i find this
can i go sign up for college i'm getting
more and more credit cards
and i got to be honest here i wouldn't
use those credit cards there was one
rope credit card that i rotated to get
breakfast
at this granola place that was it
i don't you know i'm not a big card guy
because i know at the final end
you pay for that but you got to pay for
that later on yeah that ain't free see
half of america goes lee [ __ ] it it's on
me let's go get stakes and also that
check comes in
oh that's a big number huh
that's a big [ __ ] number big number
that's that's a big number that taste
that steak don't taste that good no more
no it doesn't like chocolate cake you're
like oh jesus why would i get the
chocolate cake for 18
i know you know so it's it's it really
uh
kept it under control and then i got
divorced the attorneys the cash advances
yeah i know and i went [ __ ] over boy
and i'm just sitting there at night like
crying
writing down like [ __ ] the numbers i
only thought i was gonna pay him
and once you get behind that big wall
yeah it's
oh yeah
it's
gonna tell me boy
the best is when you're behind the wall
and you have an option
but you can't come to a conclusion that
you're gonna have to give up that
option even though in your heart
you're like i'm not gonna lose this yeah
oh i know i remember when i'm paying 10
000 one time a month
i'm like how did that kid like me
yeah i was making a few dollars
did you make paying 10 grand
i was a doorman
the [ __ ] i get off you hit me with 10
grand
all of a sudden you know you're
you're a target then years later the
judge goes well what could you
potentially make
i could potentially make who gots that's
what i could make you know what i mean
i can make zero well i can make five
dollars or maybe i make
500 or 5 000 or 15 you know who knows i
don't know
i'm in a business that's feast of famine
once you're successful i think you're
going to be successful forever
it doesn't last well you and i were
speaking about this yet there what are
you going to say like i was going to say
you were saying that 30 years goes by
like this but it really doesn't that
like in in some ways because there's
people my age buying houses i see it all
the time on facebook
and they're signing 15 30 year mortgages
and that's a long time to be tied to a
place i know you can leave
but it's not as easy as leaving like an
apartment it's
it that's whenever i see someone who i
know do that scares me
it's emotional
owning houses selling houses
you know
i've gone through it
because i lost my childhood house
i didn't pay we got there i walked them
when i wanted i left what i wanted i
opened up the refrigerator it was always
something that was nice right good
country america
still the best then the house got yanked
i never really had
for years you ever go back
to the house yeah to the front of it
yeah
i think it's too powerful in there still
i think it'll take me on a wild journey
i'll never recover from it'll take me
months to recover from so why open up
that door i'm only 53.
it would take me three years to uncover
the journey in that [ __ ] house
but there's nothing like the house she
grew up in right i mean it's like we had
a two bedroom finished basement one
bathroom
one freaking bathroom these were
bathroom people my brothers my phone we
survived
i don't know how i i remember like
people clashing we must have all went at
different times i don't remember but
somehow it worked
you need at least two bathrooms i don't
know how we survived but one
when you walked in that smell like farts
that's the worst thing in the morning
farts when you walk into a bathroom and
somebody took a [ __ ] yeah and you know
and it still has that warmth in the air
yeah
that's why you got to flush right i tell
people flush my god you walk in there
that warmth that [ __ ] oh i hate that
right for the big intestine
you let it out
i mean it hits the water yeah it's like
two seconds of that gas that triples
yeah and this [ __ ] didn't open
the window and you walked into it in the
morning wow
i wanted to cry i know i wanted to cry
like when i used to be in prison and all
that [ __ ]
nothing bothers me more
than smelling like rotten [ __ ] i know
now it's terrible like when you go to
the airport you're gonna get a piss
and you walk in there and you walk into
the center and it's like a tornado right
eight different men's [ __ ] in the middle
just spinning around
i know
sucking you in and you're like oh my god
you take a piss with your
hand covered you're covered it's
horrific it's [ __ ] horrific no you
can't i gotta run out of there
it's horrific that smells so that's why
i like to pee in the
outside in the backyard nothing like
peeing in the
backyard
just feels good i don't know as a man
it's different
i always used to be in the yard when i
was walking my dog yeah
i'm listen you got the wrong
[ __ ] i will pee
inside if they let me
you understand me if i could just get up
in the middle of night
if i could get up in the middle and i
open up my blanket with my sleep apnea
mask on
take out my little dick and if my wife
did not live with me
i would have a bottle next to me like
those hospital bottles oh my god and i
would stick my dick in that thing and
pee in the middle of night
and go right back to the avenue i've
done that many times i would have to
ring a bell in the mornings for a nurse
to come in and rub my legs to get the
circulation back on you ever have to pee
in a bottle like in a car i love all
that stuff i did it one time i had that
emergency i couldn't stop
nick you're a little older
you pee 82 times a day every time you
drink an energy you lose an ounce
and if you drink tonight if you drink
another bottle of water tonight
when you get home tonight it's three
four times you're gonna wake up and it's
every time you get settled ba-boom i
know and you pissed and you can't
believe your wife my wife are going to
meet what were you drinking last night
it sounded like a horse was pissed
it's like a machine young league you
can't figure out what you drank and
you're like all right this is the last
time i pee an hour and a half later it's
been happening to me too
oh it does are you raised i think maybe
how old is lee 28. he's a young pup he's
a pup 28 i've been i've been paying a
lot
i don't know
i've had my checkup i'm fine but
i
shouldn't be peeing that much at that
age
i don't get up at night that much no
i see that she gets up
twice a night
not twice once and a half a night
he averages like once and a half a night
because one time he'll get up not to
piss he'll get up looking for cookies he
might believe he's looking for a burglar
you're only saying that because you know
exactly you do the same thing when you
wake up stone still what do i do get
cookies you get the munchies joe
are you a snacker
i'm a [ __ ] nutcase i always feel like
i gotta eat something okay my wife
i'll tell her 18 times do me a favor
don't buy this [ __ ] okay do me a favor i
come home a week later i open up the
cabinet at night
what do you think is in there [ __ ]
cookies two different types
one of them is my favorite what is it
one of them are stabbing the heart over
famous amos
orioles
just a regular
she'll get a bag of that lisa yet for
the audience listening i can walk past
that [ __ ] for three weeks
and not touch that thing i could eat 80
stars not touch it
i would go home at night and drink water
or maybe i'll pop a little iced tea with
lemon and some fake sugar but i don't
break down and drink there's always
two three four cans of
coke zero or whatever i hate cokes it
takes them for a while it takes them to
go i'm not a big i'm i'm done i'm done
with soda
but there's [ __ ] at my house to drink
what's the story what's the point i'm
getting at least you know what the [ __ ]
i'm going
i'm waiting yeah i was waiting for the
punchline the what
waiting to find out
that's what i'm trying to get from you
what's the point of the story i'm so
[ __ ] high
i got two stone dudes right on the side
of me
that mold stone that i can't they're
trying to get to the point
it's all right
no what the [ __ ] the point was but it
really is what about chips you like
chips remember when was a kid
we used to have a potato chip man you
still we didn't have money but you had
everybody had like a soda man used to
come to the house dr brown soda we had
an ant guy named charles chips they were
good they come in a big barrel
it's good [ __ ] man i was always more of
a wise potato chip type of [ __ ]
why is this good too i fact when i was
back east for this autograph show
i had a bag of wise potato chips in my
room and i was like wow you can't find
wise out here you know i like cape cod i
like it cape cod ain't bad i like the
sea salt one
um what's the one back east that i love
you can't even get it here
oh it's a great great potato chip
there's certain things you can't get
here
it's amazing that trump is close to
winning
and people
are locking up their doors they're
thinking fidel took over
it's [ __ ] tremendous oh my god
i can't wait to see the south park
episode
that's gonna be tremendous
unbelievable well
welcome to the real world ladies and
gentlemen
it's 2017.
at times i look at my three-year-old and
i go what the [ __ ] what i blew this to
this poor girl by the time she gets to
high school this will be run by [ __ ]
people with machine guns on the corners
evading [ __ ] missiles from isis
they'll be isis neighborhoods you can
only walk in certain neighborhoods
imagine this
that's a true reality of the way we're
going here over here yeah i know it's
scary
i know
now we're going to get your tv shows
something about cooking a roller skating
show
there's got to be something for you i'm
going to make a call i'm going to talk
to my people and see so look for your
people yeah you call your people call
mine call those facebook people it's so
funny i don't even know anybody at cesar
read the pilot
we got you in there you'd be a regular
you know there's just so many forums i
know
for television oh no it's it's not now
uh you gotta go with the times
i mean even i gotta i gotta modernize i
gotta you know get with it my son
everybody's
you know you gotta you gotta get with it
dad you know you're like left you look
like live in the end
what does he want you to do no he just
you know he wants me to
you know
maybe give up cable yeah
don't be so this don't be so that i go
that's what i am i can't be something
i'm not
you know gotta get in better shape this
don't be so new york maybe you're too
new york i'm like come on
that's what i i'm to new york
he's a california kid but he's you know
he's ambitious he's rapping he's doing
the whole kanye thing and
writing raps writing beeps
you know i i don't know i don't get it
all i mean i have an open mind
you know
you also need an envelope from time to
time right this house don't cost that's
right i got to pay for your school yeah
nobody shows up here with a [ __ ]
that's right
thank you you know i'm trying to do a
family faith-based movie i'm trying to
do this movie i'm trying to do that and
because i need to put food on the table
you know what i mean you know i always
had a thing that my mother stayed alive
i would always
uh stay home you know in the back of my
mind i think about who [ __ ] wants to
stay home
when you're 20 the first thing you want
to do is get the [ __ ] out of the house
right for reasons i don't know you know
everybody has their own particular
reasons
i always start staying at home which is
always a good enough reason but
looking at it from a parent now a
different perspective
i don't know i wouldn't want somebody to
stay home but what does an 18 year old
do in today's world
to make money today
i don't know my niece is working
at a place i didn't get the whole story
here she's working at a place like let's
pretend
let's pretend uh leon's
a restaurant and the pipe broke and
soaked the restaurant
she comes in with six people and they
clean everything they take the water and
put hoses and take all the
moisture out of your carpet and they add
chemicals so it don't stink
they get it right back to how it looked
before you got hit with the [ __ ] war
i think she gets a percentage she gets
like
you know 32 percent of the job i don't
don't quote me on that i have no idea
i ask how many hours does she work and
she tells me so it's like 14 bucks an
hour
but she's a supervisor now and she's
moved up you know yeah she works six
[ __ ] days a week though
two weeks ago she washed up a crime
scene some guy committed suicide
stabbed himself upside down or something
did you clean the car
you know you can't pay me [ __ ]
3 000 and wipe that [ __ ] up you know
right
so it's just uh what does an 18 year old
do
okay
when i was growing up there was a thing
called the paper route i know i had one
i had two of them yeah a child could
deliver a paper out and learn how to
have human contact exactly and how to
collect money collect the money
get a bonus from the newspaper people
yeah there were so many big deals when i
was a child i know that yeah i'm sorry i
was gonna say i think that hustle has
turned into lyft
to be honest with you you can make a
living doing that i mean what's left
the drivers i'm talking about
i think being 10 11 and 12
to giving them a work ethic already at
that age right
okay i had the opportunity
to have be have and i had the
opportunity from
within my home and i had the opportunity
from
people that i met that said you're
looking for a summer job right my
father's hiring people to pick up bricks
for six months
and it was a [ __ ] job but she did it but
you did it and you and you understood
and you put away a thousand bucks right
for the summer and you bought clothes
and you fixed the stereo in your car
it's really [ __ ] crazy
so you build them up by the time they go
to high school now they know what the
value of a dollar is well last year he
made me wash his car for 800 that for
the summer you know
you get to learn all those jobs have
gone away there's so many things
that went away
that it wasn't about the money no it was
about
there you go
you know learning how to
the value of of something it's like the
paper route so now a child his freshman
year goes into school
and he goes you know what yeah
i can't wait for this year to be over
because uncle lee
is taking me his print shop
for eight
weeks in a row i'm going to make 10
bucks an hour i'm going to work 60 hours
a week in my uncle lee i'm going to make
a bunch of money i'm gonna come on
sometime i'm gonna have this or this
amount of money i can't do the math in
my head that quick
and they had something to live for in a
way
now that whole time is nothing they
either babysit
work at some stupid ice cream store
right for five bucks an hour and they
gotta give a piss test and they gotta
give them their [ __ ] firstborn so
these kids are raised with no real work
ethic no and now you put them in the
upper market and that place dries the
[ __ ] up what are they gonna do
work in the store as a stocker and [ __ ]
like that
they don't even have those positions no
more
when i was a kid you walk into any place
if you walked into 20 places and said
hey
you need somebody to stock shelves here
one place would finally break and go
yeah i can use some money you pull close
to the back stock them here right get
the size as [ __ ] yeah i knew tons of
people did that you worked in the deli
and learned how to slice you know make
sandwiches
whatever i don't know who
i don't know what government
i don't know what the republican or
democrat i don't this is what baffles me
what happened to all those little
positions
that got kids ready for the [ __ ]
world
i i to be honest i think a lot of people
who lost their job to doing it now when
i was working there there were a lot of
adults who were working there and
i hear more and more that people and
kids in high school can't get the jobs
that i got
at cvs or radio shack or the movie
theater
i'm i'm not sure if we could get it
anymore
because i think there's a lot of people
who
graduated college and are qualified
but can't get other jobs
so they go for the job they can get
it's crazy because
and when i was in high school i was part
of the
cie work study program
so you got five 15 credits for being
part of the program
you had to be there for first class
every day it's 7 30.
you went downstairs and you talked about
different careers what was upcoming
what was available for you in your field
by the time you got out of high school
but if you took that course
you only had to take
like you were out of that at 12 15.
but the requirement was you had to have
your own job
or find the job to the school that was
the requirement right so there was
people like my friend venery he hired
you did you drive the car no but you
washed it you waxed it by hand you
vacuumed it you vacuumed the chapel
you pulled out the caskets you took the
boxes off them you pulled the
formaldehyde you know you did [ __ ] like
that that
is shocking for some people he didn't
make you pick up bodies from time to
time
if they were shorthand and a
delivery pick came up like they just
picked the body up at the airport and
they come back and you happen to be
there you just picked up the [ __ ]
body and went inside it was no big deal
like you just knew when somebody pulled
up you hung with venery
when somebody pulled up you just got the
body what's going on buddy how you doing
friend the guy will look at you go fresh
from kennedy airport all the way from
[ __ ] bermuda and you look at the guy
and he'd be awful yeah
but venery even gave you a little salary
you always had a hustle
the church would give you these stickers
to sell
if you sold them for two bucks
you got [ __ ] a dollar or something
like that and people would buy them they
don't do that [ __ ] no more so the
children don't accept that they took
away the [ __ ] paper route i know
that's what this computer whoever
[ __ ] put the computer and news they
took they put that business
out
the newspaper business
it was good it was a good place you know
it was good to read good to get the news
but i mean
i missed that you know there's
you're right the internet the web
it's too much
it's just like you say we're over
saturated with everything just like with
baseball i say we're over saturated
we're back to being a little more
innocent that was the beauty of baseball
i have to overanalyze everything i don't
need these cybo metric guys and tell me
this i watch the game with my eyes
that's why i tweet while i'm watching
it and it comes right out of my heart
and it's the truth
you meet the stars too no stars
you're dropping the straight on uncle
joey yeah lee how you doing over there
brother i'm doing pretty good i haven't
seen the devil i'm pretty [ __ ] up i
don't know why how many i don't know how
many we had what does it matter not
really all that matters you're having a
good time with your uncle joey that's it
you headed to boston i'll be in a few
days [ __ ] yeah we're doing the will
bethina which is sold out if i know
anything about uncle bill he'll find
somewhere to put you in the dungeon and
you can see it through periscope he'll
do something oh yeah yeah
my uncle bill he don't give a [ __ ] he'll
find a way to get a dollar out of you so
just show up at the gate i'm sure
there'll be something there for you if
not
i'll be over at the fox woods casino
in connecticut on saturday night how's
that one for you buddy somebody's trying
to get a copy that deported
all right there you go you gotta get to
the porters you want some real [ __ ]
laughs
and that's it and the week after that
november 18th i'm on the what come and
take it comedy festival
in houston there's tickets available go
to
uh come and get a comedy festival stuff
like
great stuff is going on guys that's what
i'm trying to [ __ ] tell you
is here no joey coco
one of the funniest bastards in america
the tour won't break
he's been approached by 15 different
scientologists organizations don't
believe a word he said yes they have
i have a friend they tried to get me in
the pool years ago not those the other
one they're born again
i know
10 years we break yeah
that's the spirit's talking oh my god
just say to be careful there we go be
nice thank you thank you i'm not saying
nothing negative for you no no i'm just
i'm doing the job
be nice here i'm just messing with you
people yeah frankie there you go you got
a little water that means something's
going down here
that's a little blessing for you lee get
a little water let me give you something
right there salute
salute
look what you did though
i've apologized
no worries you know i love you
what do you apologize joey loves you i'm
worried let me tell you something guys
all right we've been working with these
guys for a year
if you look at my drawers
i got thousands of pairs of this if i go
to jiu jitsu
if i go to the gym listen if i put
shorts on
i put me on these on why a few reasons
comfort they keep me together and they
keep me dry
that is it
picture a world where putting on a new
pair underwear isn't just fresh
you're stepping into a better day you
wake up in the morning you come out of
the shower you're feeling positive bam
you got new underwear oh it's the first
thing you put on the last thing you take
off when they're all sweaty and they
smell like three dead goats but why
would you settle for anything less than
the best
feeling underwear on the planet me
undies focuses solely on producing the
most comfortable underwear you're ever
gonna experience my friends at miami
sent me a few pairs like i said i got a
draw
and every month they sent me a new print
and it's always different i can't
imagine wearing anything else okay it
really makes each day
a lot better
including the price of the underwear is
the sweet touch of modal a special
fabric with the best in class raw
materials that are scientifically proven
to be three times softer than cotton
they keep your nut sac dry your muffler
dry
they keep everything in place you feel
good when you wear them i'm a fat buck i
don't feel good when i wear underwear
when i put on me undies i feel like a
new man
these uber cozy undies are sold
exclusively on the undies website where
you enjoy free shipping
to the us and canada listen to what i'm
going to tell you after a limited time
for a limited time everyone in my
audience gets 20
off
their first order but you got to go to
our special url
meundies.com
joey again meundies.com
joey
they each touch with a moldor a special
fabric three times softer than cotton
with the me undies better day guarantee
you have
nothing to lose so don't wait any longer
go to meundies.com
joey right now for 20 off your first
order all right again
meundies.com
joey the best underwear you'll ever ever
ever put on all right
number two
lee loves this app because whenever he
travels
he downloads his favorite magazines i
don't know what the hell he reads on
there yes
he had something else from there he told
me one time well the texture app lets
you tap into the world's most popular
magazines anytime anywhere
using your smartphone or tablet breeze
through hundreds of your favorite
magazines
including back issues and pick the
articles that interest you the most
texture has made it easy for you to care
about i don't get i don't just read you
know rolling stone magazine the text
editorial team recommends content to me
every day plus i can dive deeper into
personalized collection
sign up protect you right now and gain
inside access to all the content
from the world's best
the best part
texture is offering my listeners a free
trial right now when you go to
texture.com joey that's right a free
trial you'll gain immediate entry into
all the top magazines including back
issues and ready for this one bonus
video content if this is your world this
is perfect for you start binge reading
for free right now when you go to
texas.com
joey and don't forget the most important
thing guys i need you guys for this
there's a big favor of me i asked you
guys for everything
you know i love you
from my man blake out there in columbus
ohio i never got to tell you how much i
love you
sam blake all you [ __ ] there
listen i need a big favor from you guys
i shot my special in chicago
congratulations on the world series one
of the best cities in the world that's
why i shot my special there i need a
favor it's just you guys
december 8th my special comes out all
right
there's a a channel called cso tv it's
tremendous it's got the old saturn live
it's got original programming it's got
some stuff that won some awards do me a
favor my special's gonna air there if
you sign up today right now you're gonna
get two months for free
and you get my special for free
and you're doing me a favor so do me a
favor
go to cso
what is it dot com slash joey cso.com
joey and press in joey j-o-e-y right now
as soon as the podcast lens do this for
me as a personal favor
click on the interested in the special
when it comes out watch it
call me a fat [ __ ] pig i don't give a
[ __ ] you did me a favor that's why i
love you because you're doing me favors
we do each other favors you scratch my
back i scratch your [ __ ] back and we
all have a good time all right i need
you to do this for me all right so i
want to thank honett i want to thank
texture i want to thank cecil for
putting my special on please go there
and get two months of freeze done right
now
j-o-e-y
and i want to thank meundies.com and
i'll see you [ __ ] at fox woods
saturday night i want to thank my men
nick tutorial for coming down
cracking some jokes i always loved this
guy with all my heart thank you buddy he
doesn't need these stars because he'll
have a heart attack yeah
my pleasure but we'll tighten them up
all right looking forward to ufc thank
you brother usc new york oh you going no
i
like mcgregor all right my man your
bedroom no i don't bet him i just dig
him i like him and the other guy diaz
that guy's funny too she better nate
diaz
i don't know i mean i don't know i'm
starting to get into it were you bentley
i was i'm not paying anyone i was
wondering if you took off why they took
up richard evans where did you go for
russia evans do you know they took them
off the car yeah something
medical they know i don't know thank you
for telling me listen guys thank you for
listening have a great weekend no matter
what happens you still got to push
through your life and as bad as it
[ __ ] seems it ain't cuba [ __ ]
they're not gonna come take your house
and make you buy it back all right
thank you very much for watching and
listen i love you guys i'll see you
monday stay blackish
this
so
the world will be
wow
me
far away
forever
you